ми говоримо з міністеркою освіти та науки Ганною Новосад.
Доброго дня!
Вітаю!
Перше питання,звичайно,про НУШ.
Імовірно, Ви вже зробили попередній аудитситуації?
Які головні негативні та позитивні результати Ви бачите?
Почну з позитиву. На мою думку,
є доволі очевидним, що ті нововведення, які розпочалися в школі
в початковій школі, позитивно сприймаються на загал суспільством,
позитивно сприймаєтьсявчителями, батьками,
і, що головне, учнями і ученицями, які, за нашимидослідженнями,
почувають себе щасливішими в школі.
Іце, на мою думку, є головним.
Великий мінус, я сподіваюся, він з часом виправиться,
це, звичайно, імплементація реформи на місцях.
Ми досі маємо багато проблем з закупівлями,
з вчасними закупівлямиобладнання, дидактики,
всього того, чим ми маємо наповнити новий освітній простір
КористувачіDWскаржаться на те, що не в усіх школах є
смарт-дошки, не в усіх школах є ті красиві Лего-онструктори
Навіть, не в усіх школах є парти.
Що з фінансуванням цього року на НУШ?
Станом на заразна цей рік, в нас досі ще не вся
субвенція на НУШ, на закупівлідосі не є використаною.
Станом на вересень, це було всього менше 50%.
Чекаємо нових цифр на жовтень,
Вочевидь, проблема з вчасними закупівлями, вона залишається.
Саме томуможуть виникати такі питання,
чого немає, наприклад, парт.
Але, що стосується класів, якінаразі не є охоплені реформою,
це, наприклад, базова школа нинішня,
ми чудово розуміємо, що ми не можемо,
скажімо так, розрізняти, хто для нас краще чиважливіше:
початковашкола чи базова.
І той і той рівеньважливий. Завжди питання в ресурсах.
Але вже на наступний рік ми хочемо мати і будемо мати
цільові кошти для покращення освітнього простору
вопорних школах на всіх рівнях -
і в базовій, і в старшій школі.
Чи відчули Ви, можливо, що неусі вчителі підтримують НУШ?
Не усі вчителі розуміють її сенс,
не усі вчителі мають достатньо якихось наказів, вказівок,
інструкцій, як це взагалі впроваджувати?
Звичайно, скільки людей - стільки думок.
І кожен вчительв цій країні, який є професіоналом,
може мати і має мати свою думкущодо тих нововведень, які розпочалися.
Проте ми бачимо, що є надзвичайно велика когорта агентів змін -
тих вчителів, які ці зміни підтримують,
і з часом вони переконуються, що ці всі практики,
які в НУШ запропоновані, вони, насправді, діють.
Ті діяльності в навчанні. Ті, на перший погляд, елементарні речі,
як-от ранкове коло, чиякісь інші елементи навчального процесу,
вони, насправді, є дієвими.
Чи встигли Ви вже оцінити рівень знань учнів,
які вони отримали в НУШ?
Ми не оцінюємо рівень знань як такий.
Зараз ми робимо моніторингові дослідження.
Український центр дослідження якості освіти провів першу хвилю,
очікуємо наступний рік другу.
Мета ж не перевірити оцінки, а мета перевірити ставлення дітей,
чи краще вони встигають опановувати програму,
як вони себе почувають в НУШ.
Думаю,з рокамими, насправді, будемо мати краще розуміння того,
як все-таки реформа впливає на прогрес учнів в навчанні.
Вчителі та батьки скаржаться на те, що діти не встигають засвоїти програму.
І це буде мати негативні наслідки вже в третьому класі...
Я,чесно кажучи, таких звернень не чула.
Чула навпаки інші думки.
Якщо є такі звернення, ми готові їхрозглядати.
Програми, як такі, вони можуть переглядатися.
Власне, це те, що нам необхідно буде робити.
Але наразі рухаємося з впровадженням тих програм, які були розроблені.
Що Ви скажете на пропозиції від батьків, що треба повертати щоденники?
Таке рішення може бути прийнято,
проте ми все-таки рекомендуємо утримуватися
від таких практик, принаймні, впочатковій школі.
Можливо, батькам хочеться мати більше контролю над процесом.
Але філософія НУШ полягає в довірі,
в тому числі, між батьками і вчителями.
І відверто кажучи, є прихильникомтого,
аби дати шанс розкритися цій довірі, все-таки дати їйшанс.
Оцінювання в 3-ому класі буде скасовано.
Чи можете Ви це підтвердити?
В початковій школі оцінювання відбуватиметься…
підсумково, в кінці рокуви будете мати свідоцтводосягнень.
Це не просто який абстрактнийтабель.
Свідоцтво досягнень є тим інструментом,
який дуже глибокорозкриває,
як дитина опанувалиті чи інші навички, компетентності,
як вона їх засвоїла, як вона себе поводить в школі,як вона себе соціалізує в школі.
Наскільки великий дефіцит вчителів в початковій школі?
В нас є дефіцит вчителів в великих містах.
Це те, що ми чуємо від місцевих управлінь і самих шкіл.
Проте, дефіциту по країні, як такого, не спостерігається.
Єдине, над чим ми будемо працювати,
над таким створенням бази вакансій.
Ця ідея давно циркулювала,і нам потрібно до цієї ідеї повернутися,
щоб зрозуміти, власне, де цей дефіцит і який він.
Заробітна платня вчителів, як вони пишуть,
лишилася на рівні прибиральниці.
Коли буде підвищена зарплата вчителям?
Обіцяли на 10%...
10 % - це науково-педагогічні працівники.
І з вересня вони будуть її отримувати.
Зарплату необхідно підвищувати.
І є ціль, яка визначена законом про освіту
до 2023 рокувийти на певний рівень мінімальногоокладу
на рівні 4-х прожиткових мінімумів.
Минулий уряд, дійсно, затвердив постанову
про підвищення заробітних плат усім категоріям освітян.
Вийшло так, що в проекті бюджету, який отримав наш уряд,
додаткові кошти на виконання цієї постанови закладені не були.
Мишукаємо,як ми можемо вийти хоча би
на частковевиконання цієї постанови, якапередбачає,
якщо виконувати її в повному обсязі з січня2020року,
додаткових 20 млрд гривень до нашого бюджету.
Ми зараз працюємо над тим, щоб знайти певне компромісне рішення,
і все-таки підвищити заробітні плати. Можливо, це буде окреме категорія
працівників, які є найбільшим вразливими.
Особливомова йде про
працівників дошкільних закладів, як вихователів, так і директорів.
Вихователь в цій країні отримує4173гривні,
це абсолютно неприспустимо за жодних умов.
Є ще молоді майстри професійно-технічного навчання у закладах профтехнічної освіти.
Це категорії, які отримують, фактично, одну з найменших зарплат у системі.
Тому принаймні для покращення їхньої ситуації ми зараз шукаємо варіанти.
Як Ви вважаєте, якою має бути заробітна платня українського вчителя?
Вона має бути такою, щоб гідно проживати в цьому суспільстві,
почувати себе вільним, мати можливість
мати нормальні умови проживання, нормальний відпочинок.
В Києві, приміром?
В Києві, аби людина нормально почувала,
це я беру вжебез якихось додаткових потреб,
на мою, думку прожити менше,
ніж на 18-20 тисяч гривень
доволіскладно. Особливо, якщо ми говоримо
не просто одну людину, а про родину.
Непідвищення заробітних плат вчителям - це підґрунтя для корупції.
Як Ви оцінюєте українські школи -
наскільки там велика корупція?
Мабуть, тут коректніше говорити не про корупцію, як таку.
А про те, щотакими невеликими заробітними платами
ми дуже часто, система дуже часто змушує вчителів
шукати, як отримати інший супутній заробіток
через репетиторство і інші речі.
Ми розуміємо, що це робиться не тому, що хочеться цим займатися,
а тому ЗП офіційна та основна,
вона не дозволяєдійсно мати достойний рівень життя.
Побори в українських школах.Це така хот-тема.
І з цим , схоже,ніхто нічого не може зробити.
Чи планується введення якоїсь окремої,
можливо, кримінальної відповідальності за це?
Не думаю, що це той випадок, коли має бути кримінальна відповідальність.
Якна мене, це трохи в іншій площині.
Законом про освіту ввелося таке поняття,
як фінансова прозорість шкіл.
Будь-якашкола має обов’язковому порядку на своєму сайті
оприлюднювати фінансову звітність своє школи.
Держава дуже довго не фінансувала утримання шкіл, це правда.
Зараз в останні два роки, і наш уряд будепродовжуй це робити,
ми працюємо над новим освітнім простором,
щоб батьки не купувалишафки,
килими, ще щось для того, щоб обладнати клас.
Єдине, що це потребує час. На наступний рік уряд виділяє
більше ніж 1,4 млрд гривень
для нового освітнього простору в початковій школі.
Тому коли батьки дітей початкової школи будуть на щосьдодатково здавати,
о виникає питання, на що пішли ті кошти держбюджету,
які пішли на субвенцію НУШ.
Є дуже багато випадків шкіл, котрі не фінансуються
з місцевих бюджетів лише тому, що їм банально ці кошти не виділяються, але вони є.
І це питання до громади розбиратися на місцевому рівні -
чому ці кошти не дійшли до школи.
Батьківські комітети, якізбирають гроші. Це добречи погано?
Я вважаю. Що батьківські комітети – це добре.
Має бути представництво батьків, спільно узгоджена позиція.
Але, вочевидь, збір коштів точно не є їх основною функцією.
Можна вважати, що місцеві департаменти освіти
навчилися вже обходити систему Прозорро?
В мене немає якихось підтверджень чи фактів, що це так.
Якщо це так, будь ласка, просимо надати факти.
В нас є проблеми з закупівлями. Але не можу сказати,
можливо, ще не розібралася з цим,
чи дійсно це пов’язано з якимось махінаціями саме з Прозорро.
Керівництво шкіл може заборонити батькам заходити в школу далі холу.
Чи можетеВи це підтвердити чи спростувати?
Я вважаю, щобатьки мають мати доступ до школи,
вони мають мати можливість дійти до класу.
Інше питання, що батьки не мають втручатися в освітній процес,
а все-таки практикувати довіруз вчителями,
які знають, як навчати їхніх дітей.
Звичайно, це не стосується прикрих випадків,
коли в школах трапляється булінг
чи якісь інші абсолютно ненормальні історіїз вчителями
Чи у Васякісь рецепт к запобігти булінгу в школах.
Є закон, який має працювати. Але випадки є.
Зараз, дійсно, в нас є кілька сотень штрафів,
які виписані судом за випадки булінгу,
як з боку вчителя, так і вйого бік, вчителя.
Нам необхідно працювати над етикою взаємодії,
запобігати усім можливим випадкам такогоставлення.
І це маєробитися через правильну підготовку вчителів,
через постійне їхнє підвищення кваліфікації, через окремі курси,
як протидіяти булінгу.Адже, булінг може траплятися в обидві сторони
і зараз направду ми стикаємося дуже часто з кейсами
коли вчителі є об’єктом булінгу з боку учнів,
що вчителі є такими об’єктами цькування,
що до них є набагато менше поваги, ніж того хотілося.
І це велика комунікаційна робота і з батьками, і з учнями.
Чи згодні Ви з таким твердження, що реформа в українській школі
призвела до того, що вучнів і батьків побільшало прав,
а у вчителів поменшало?
В них точно ці права не зменшилися. Навпаки, вони отримали
більше академічної свободи, можливості бути вільними
в своїй професійній діяльності.
Є певна проблема з адекватним поважним ставленням до вчителів.
Іситуація, коли чи батьки чи діти намагаються
поставити на місце вчителя
або розповісти, як краще навчати, вона є неадекватною.
Разом зНУШ існують 9 нетипових програм, за якими можна теж навчатися.
Навколо них багатоскандалів.
Як Ви ставитися до існування таких програм?
Для мене основне в ційісторії це те,
що до жодної з альтернативних програм
не має бути примусу.